welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition that's right
everyone we finally have some reports on
who John Cena will be playing in the MCU
and the upcoming show Falcon and Winter
Soldier I tried finding some footage of
Cena but there wasn't actually any of it
on the Internet
so here's some generic wrestling videos
as I discuss it but if you've been
following em Cu news for the past couple
of months you'd know that Cena had
thrown his hat or rather shield in the
ring for becoming the next Captain
America now before we go ahead any
further I just want to let you know that
there may be some spoilers here in
regards to Falcon and Winter Soldier and
is definitely spoilers for endgame and
far from home
so if you don't want to know anything
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now without the way I just want to
give a huge thank you for clicking this
video now let's get into my breakdown of
John Cena's MCU casting news ok so
originally Cena posted to his Instagram
account on November the 4th at Captain
America shield with black panther
scratches on it this obviously sent the
internet wild and there was a lot of
speculation around it with most people
guessing that he was going to take up
the mantle after Chris Evans stepped
down the internet was really excited to
see this go down but as it was pre and
game no one really knew that in the film
the torch would in fact be pastor Sam
Wilson aka Falcon this kind of quashed
the rumour mill for a while with many
assuming that Cena had just been trying
to build some hype around himself so
that Marvel execs would look his way
even though we all know they wouldn't be
able to see him it doesn't look like
Cena is out of the running now and the
actor will in fact be playing John
Walker aka u.s. agent if these rumors
proved to be true for those who don't
know a u.s. agent was originally
introduced as a villain known as super
Patriot and he's pretty much been an
antihero bouncing back and forth between
sides throughout basically his whole
history in the Falcon and Winter Soldier
TV show
u.s. agent will apparently be a
government-sanctioned Captain America
that's been put in place since the
events of civil war due to cat being a
war criminal u.s. agent will likely be
gone
head-to-head with Falcon and Bucky due
to their allegiance with the character
and also the fact that they are pretty
much carrying on his legacy now whether
these rumors are true or not we will see
but apparently the leaks say in the show
the government are pretty against Sam
picking up the name Captain America and
this is why the show is labeled as
Falcon and Winter Soldier as both will
widely be known by their outlaw status
especially Bucky who apparently was
never accepted by the government due to
his past this also adds some way to
white cap went back in time and stayed
there as had he returned to the present
and he would have still been seen as an
outlaw and arrested in far from home the
character is listed as dead and the
heroes probably did this so that cap
would never be further looked into and
he could live out the rest of his years
in peace John Cena will obviously be
going head to head with Falcon and Bucky
and this will no doubt be because the
government wanted to to be closed down
permanently I personally think if this
does come true then it will be an
outstanding premise descent of the show
around I can 100% see Cena fitting into
the role of u.s. agent the character
requires a lot of duality and Cena can
pull off being a bad guy whilst the
author has a lot of charisma that makes
him likable and easy to side with to me
this is some excellent casting and it
sounds like this show is gonna be
phenomenal I kind of felt like it was
going to be slightly disappointing and I
didn't really have much hype for it but
now with this news I really think it'll
work it means that Falcon is really
gonna have to earn the title Captain
America and it will make for some
amazing drama and no doubt another thing
that comes from this is that Cena is of
course a no stranger to movies and Kevin
Feige head of marvel at Disney has
already said that there will be
crossovers from the show's into the
movies so I think Cena could bounce back
between the two quite easily it's got me
really really excited and I think
getting such a big name involved in the
project will definitely get fans on
board obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on this news and if you're
excited as I am for the upcoming show
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my breakdown
over all the times that Nick Fury was a
well you know what in the MCU which
would be linked at the end I give my fan
theories on the switchovers and it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more I also just want to
let you know that we're giving away a
free copy of Avengers and
on blu-ray - one lucky winner and all
you have to do is like this video make
sure that you subscribe to the channel
and leave your thoughts on this news in
the comments below the winner will be
chosen at random on August the 10th and
the blu-ray will be shipped out from
then to ever get surprised best of luck
to everyone who takes part and I'll see
you next time Cheers
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for take the time to watch
this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]